in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
graph logarithmic functions with
transformations so the form that we're
gonna be working with here is y equals
log base B of X minus h plus K so you've
already probably learned how to graph
exponential functions they're graphs
that look something like this where
there
you're either exponential growth or
exponential decay but what logarithmic
functions are is they're inverses of
exponential functions when you graph an
inverse of a function you're reflecting
it over this line y equals x so our la
graphs are gonna look something like
this where they're going up like slower
and slower and the main thing with
working with logarithmic graphs is
knowing how to switch from the Log form
to the exponential form because we're
usually not so familiar with thinking in
terms of logs so if we can transform it
into an exponential form it's a little
bit easier to get a graph so we're going
to go through four examples we're going
to start easy and get progressively more
challenging so let's start off with a
basic one y equals log base 2 of X the
first thing I like to do is rewrite this
as a exponential function so this is our
base this is our power and this is our
answer now I've got a video about how to
change forms if you have trouble with
that you can go ahead and check that out
but one method that's helpful to
students is see how this is log base 2
you can exponentiate both sides using
base 2 okay in the exponential function
the logarithmic function they're
inverses they cancel so you've got 2 to
the Y power equals ax ok now what I like
to do is make a table the only
difference here is that instead of
substituting it for the X values we're
going to substitute in for the Y values
it's a little bit easier because Y is in
the exponent or power position so let's
just go ahead and put in a few values
negative 1 0 1 to 2 to the negative 1 is
1/2 because remember when you have a
negative exponent you take the
reciprocal 2 to the 0 is 1 2 to the
first is 2 and 2 to the second is 4 now
we're going to plot those points from
the origin so we're going to go right a
1/2 down 1 1 comma 0 so we're going
right 1 up 0 to 1 so we're going right
to up 1 and then 4 to 1/2
three four up to and so what you can see
here is that the graph is getting you
know it's going up but it's going up
like at a slower and slower rate and
it's gradually getting closer and closer
to the y-axis this is our vertical
asymptote it's the line x equals zero
vertical lines are x equals lines so the
domain here
what can X be well the domain is going
to be X has to be greater than meaning
to the right of but not equal to zero
so it gets close to zero but doesn't
touch the range the y-values are gonna
be all real numbers because this goes
down towards negative infinity this
graduate goes up towards positive
infinity so that's your basic graph just
remember vertical asymptotes for the
logarithm logarithms for number two now
we're building on what we did in number
one the only difference is see how it's
log base two but now we have minus 1 and
plus 3 so what does this one do to the
graph what does this 3 do to the graph
what you want to remember is whatever is
group with the ax here that's gonna
shift the graph in the X direction okay
left and right all right it has the
opposite effect so the -1 is actually
going to shift it right one this one has
the same effect it's going to go up
three and what I like to do is just draw
like an open circle there we're going to
think of it as our new origin so this is
what shifts the graph ur translates the
graph then I like to draw any vertical
asymptotes this is the line x equals 1
the graphs can get closer to that line
and then what we can do is we can focus
in on this parent function since we've
already taken the shift into account y
equals log base 2 of X and that's what
we had graphed already or found the
points are in this table so we're gonna
graph these points from this new
starting point so we're gonna go write
1/2 down 1 right 1 comma 0 right 2 up 1
and then right 4 from this point here 1
2 3 4 up to and so you can see the
graphs looking something like that and
you can see it's getting closer and
closer that asymptote x equals 1
now here the domain is going to be X is
greater than 1 whereas the range is
going to be all real numbers so you're
probably noticing that the range is
always all real numbers
all Y values are possible but the domain
is going to be you're gonna have to pay
attention to the shift here and that's
this number here this group with yeah so
let's do two more examples see if you
can do these on your own and we'll go
through them together so you can get
some more practice if you're new to the
channel and we're meeting for the first
time my name is Mario of Mario's math
tutoring and this channel is all about
making learning math less stressful so
you can raise your grade pass your class
and go on to pursue your dreams so if
that's something that sounds interesting
to you
check out more math videos on my Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel and I've
also got math courses available Algebra
one algebra two as well as ECT math and
SAT Math that you can check out if
you're interested so let's go through
number three and four together and the
first thing here I like to do is take a
look at the translation or the shift so
in this case you can see this pulse two
has the opposite effect it's shifting
left 2 and down 2 so we're going left 2
down 2 and remember I like to draw that
is like an open circle we're gonna think
of it as like our new starting point I
also like to draw in the vertical
asymptotes that's the line x equals
negative 2 and now what we can do is we
can focus in on the parent function
what's left over after we took that
translation into account I like to
rewrite it in the exponential form
remember this is the base this is the
power this is our answer so what we're
going to do is we're going to make a
table of values but remember instead of
substituting it for X we're gonna
substitute it for y it's a little bit
easier because Y is in the exponent
position so let's go ahead and put in
negative 2 negative 1 0 1 so if we put
in a negative 2 1/2 to the second I'm
sorry went after the negative to the
negative 2 you take the reciprocal so
that would be like 2 and then 2 squared
is 4 1/2 to the negative 1 you take the
reciprocal that's going to be 2 anything
to the 0 power is 1 anything to the
first power is itself so when we graph
these points from the new starting point
we're gonna go right for down to just
going to be right about there right to
down 1 and this one is right 1 down 0
and then right 1/2 up 1 so here what you
can see a little bit different log graph
and we're used to seeing
it's going like this instead of like
this and why is that well it's because
this base here is between zero and one
okay so it feels like a half or a third
or fourth you're going to get that type
of shape as opposed to that type of
shape there so in the case of the domain
the domain is going to be what X can be
X is going to be greater than negative
two our asymptote is x equals negative
two and then our range we said is all
real numbers
so number four see if you can do this
one this one's probably the most
challenging one we've done so far y
equals three minus log base four of the
quantity X plus one well you might be
saying well Mario this doesn't look like
it's in that form
well you see this 3 here this 3 we can
move over here so this is a positive 3
right see there's nothing to the left of
the 3 that means it's a positive 3 which
is like plus 3 and now I'm just going to
erase this okay the negative still stays
here this is a negative log what do you
think the negative does to the graph
well you're making all the Y values the
opposite it's going to reflect it over
the x axis but let's go ahead and follow
the pattern we've been doing so far
which is taking the shift into account
first we're going to be shifting not
positive 1 but to the left negative 1
this one's the opposite plus 3 it has
the same effect we're going up 3 so
we're going to think of that as our new
origin or our new starting point right
now we've taken that into account so now
we're down to this parent function of y
equals negative log base 4 of X see this
negative here let's go ahead and
multiply both sides by negative 1 just
to get this log by itself and now we're
going to rewrite it in exponential form
remember this is the base this is the
power and this is the answer so what
we're going to do is we're going to make
a table substituting values in for Y not
X so negative 1 0 1 let's just try those
3 so 4 to the negative x negative 1
that's like 4 to the positive 1 which is
4 4 to the 0 which is going to be 1 4 to
the negative 1 remember the negative you
take the reciprocal 1 4
so we're going to plot these points now
from our new starting point our new
origin so we're going to go right for
one two three four down one it's gonna
be right about there one zero so right
one but up zero and then right one
fourth up one and there's our graph like
that and it keeps going down down down
like that up up up so the range is all
real numbers but the domain is going to
be X is greater than negative one and
our vertical asymptote is x equals
negative one so that was a challenging
one if you want to see more examples
specifically about working with
logarithms not just graphing logarithms
but solving logarithmic equations
learning how to switch the different
forms how to evaluate logs kind of like
a comprehensive like logarithmic review
video follow me over to that video right
there and we'll dive into logs